última prueba de confianza los turcos
deciden entre dos opciones políticas
para los próximos cinco años
representados en quemalquix taroglu y
receptáy el mandatario votó en Estambul
erdoan se mostró confiado en la rapidez
del proceso y elogió el sistema
electoral
partidario esta vez no hay partidos
políticos en la boleta y el papel no
mide un metro de largo solo hay dos
candidatos y como nuestro pueblo solo
votará por eso creo que la votación de
hoy terminará muy rápido por primera vez
en la historia de la Democracia turca
estamos presenciando una segunda Ronda
de elecciones presidenciales
al salir del colegio cientos de personas
se le mostraron su apoyo por su parte su
principal contendor que listaroglu votó
en ankara el líder opositor que cuenta
con el respaldo unificado de seis
partidos políticos instó a los
ciudadanos a defender la democracia
estimados miembros de la prensa invito a
todos nuestros ciudadanos a las urnas
para que la verdadera democracia y las
libertades puedan finalmente llegar a
nuestro país para acabar con la opresión
y el régimen autoritario que cada uno
emita su voto y luego proteja la boleta
su simpatizantes lo vitorearon como el
presidente del pueblo al término del
sufragio
el estado de opinión de los turcos
cuenta con un factor común la esperanza
de continuar mejorando el país
tengo esperanza en esta lección tengo
esperanza en el futuro esta será una
elección importante para nuestra
juventud y nuestra nación Espero que
nuestros ciudadanos tomen la decisión
correcta
en la primera vuelta erdogan ganó el
voto popular aunque no alcanzó las
papeletas necesarias para hacerse con el
poder